comenzamos esta edición de deportes
domingo hablando de fútbol femenino
vamos a analizar la copa américa que se
juega aquí en colomi también la eurocopa
de inglaterra vamos a comenzar con la
copa américa porque acaba de terminar la
cuarta fecha del grupo a por eso
contamos con la presencia de sara castro
directora de deportes de caracol radio y
del hierbas colombia olas hará bueno
ahora querrán un gusto estar con ustedes
como siempre vamos a empezar entonces
como les decíamos con esa copa américa
femenina acabamos de ver que colombia
viene de ganar a ecuador 9 puntos de 9
para las locales en este torneo
virtualmente clasificados a semifinales
ya pero igualmente es sabido estamos
viendo sobre todo en este grupo a
muchísima paridad si yo creo que el
partido frente a ecuador demuestra eso
básicamente desde el juego y desde el
nivel que han alcanzado de las
diferentes selecciones sudamericanas en
este torneo yo creo que el trabajo de
emily lima a pesar de que ecuador en
este punto sólo tiene una victoria
frente a bolivia que es el equipo que ya
está eliminado y que no jugará en la
última fecha descansa en esa fecha han
demostrado un avance en cuanto al
desarrollo técnico al desarrollo táctico
y sobre todo una cohesión grupal que
también es importante en este tipo de
entonces estamos viendo a una selección
colombia que llega a esta última jornada
con nueve puntos de nueve posibles
evidentemente favorita por su localía
hoy hubo
24.580 personas en el pascual guerrero
acompañando a la selección de colombia
pero también vemos a chile que después
de un inicio difícil empieza a recuperar
este digamos a recuperar esa memoria
paraguay que tampoco deja nada y en esta
última jornada en la que colombia se
enfrenta a chile y ecuador a paraguay
sin duda siguen muchas cosas en juego y
no hay nada definido hasta este momento
ahora vamos a méndy que otras
selecciones en el otro grupo en el grupo
que con procesos que también han sido
muy interesantes hay algo que a mí me
llama mucho la atención es lo de
venezuela y es que si bien él le ha
ganado tanto a perú como uruguay uruguay
que es la gran decepción de este grupo
porque lo hemos visto en torneos
internacionales como copa libertadores
con jugadores muy interesantes y con un
proceso llamativo y hasta ahora ya
completó tres derrotas en lo que va del
campeonato te duele sólo me parece muy
interesante porque tiene un partido
frente a brasil y brasil si bien tiene
no sólo una historia un potencial enorme
creo que si pone de presente y pone a
prueba lo que está haciendo
me la complicó con este con este equipo
pamela conti reina castellanos va a
tener un reto yo creo que todo este
trabajo defensivo que ha hecho la
entrenadora italiana se va a haber
puesto a prueba ante un rival muy fuerte
y como decía el cholo simeone cuando
habla del atletico de madrid está muy
bien eso que los equipos se preparen
para hacer su mejor partido mientras el
rival pueda no tener un gran partido y
creo que esta medida va a ser muy
interesante en este grupo b en el que
argentina también ha remontado le hemos
visto mejor fútbol después de caer
goleado ante brasil
estos insisto para mí la gran sorpresa
es el bajo rendimiento de uruguay porque
creo que lo de perú a falta de un
proceso más consolidado pues ya se veía
venir así se esperaba más de uruguay
tenemos que hablar también de la
eurocopa femenina como les decíamos
tenemos a siete de los ocho equipos
clasificados acuerdos en la tierra de
españa alemania austria suecia francia y
países bajos
sara hablemos del rendimiento de algunas
de esas selecciones favoritas que ya
superaron la primera fase empecemos por
el gran duelo que se viene en los
cuartos de final que sin duda es
inglaterra españa una inglaterra
imbatible con nueve de nueve puntos pero
además 14 goles a favor sera es un
equipo que realmente no ha tenido
posición en este torneo pero sin duda a
medida que va avanzando el torneo
evidentemente tácticamente ya vamos a
ver cómo se le plantea el resto de
equipos en este caso españa que superó
sin duda esa caída que tuvo en este
primer partido en esta primera fase y
que está consolidando un juego a pesar
de la ausencia de alexia putellas así
que yo creo que es uno de los partidos
más llamativos de esta primera de este
primero partido primera jornada de
cuartos de final ahora vamos con la
alemania otro de los grandes favoritos
multi campeones de europa campeones
mundiales 9 de 9
y también una gran producción goleadora
yo creo que ahí es donde está la
diferencia la experiencia que pueda
tener frente a austria que es la gran
sorpresa tras haber clasificado en este
grupo de inglaterra superó incluso a al
equipo de
noruega exactamente con una de las
grandes balón de oro ahí así que yo creo
que este también ese partido es muy
interesante y yo creo que lo siguiente
es lo de francia francia ha tenido
varias bajas en su nómina y si bien no
ha tenido esta potencia goleadora de
equipo como inglaterra o como países
bajos yo creo que lo que ha demostrado
esta experiencia para dominar este tipo
de torneos y como digo a medida que va
avanzando ya empezamos a ver es la
jerarquía con la que se dominan estos
escenarios durante el juego
evidentemente la primera fase si nos
demostró que hay equipos un poco más
débiles en referencia a otras grandes
potencias por equipos consolidados y
también por individualidades que están
muy asentadas en esos equipos